Okay, someone asked a question. Marie
asked the question as to why the didn't
recognize Jesus. Yes, we need I need
further clarification. She goes, I'd
like clarification as to why the suffer.
If you go to John chapter 20 and if you
read verses 1-15, we are told why in
that particular
instance, in that particular instance,
Mary Magdalene did not recognize the
Lord Jesus Christ. Why? Uh because it
was early in the morning. She wasn't
looking in his direction. And secondly,
she was pretty much wailing. She was in
deep mourning, weeping bitterly cuz she
thought they had stolen the body. But
then when Jesus called out to her, Mary,
she recognized because she turned and
looked at him and said,
"Raboni." So that accounts for it.
Number one, early in the
morning, she's weeping bitterly. She's
mourning bitterly.
and she wasn't looking in his direction.
So in that particular instance, if she's
referring to Luke 24, when you read that
the Lord appeared to the two on the road
of Emmas, it says because they were kept
from recognizing him. So if you read the
narrative, you'll see there they were
kept from recognizing him. So most
likely if the Lord had appeared, he may
have been veiled. He may have had a veil
over him. Whatever the reason, the Lord
prevented them from recognizing him
immediately due to their unbelief and
hardness of hearts. Because if you read
the narrative, if you go brother in Luke
24 and you can start reading from verse
10 onwards, it says
that they were heartbroken and
disappointed thinking that he was the
one who was going to come and redeem
Israel. However, his death on the cross
shattered their hopes. And then they say
something interesting. He goes,
"Besides, it's the third day since all
of these things happened." Notice it's
the third day since all of these things
happened. In fact, brother, if you can
open up Luke 24 for everyone to see
right now, if you go start at 9 so we
can read the resurrection appearance and
read slowly all the way. You can read
the 24, but start at nine. Okay? When
they came back from the tomb, they told
all these things to the 11 and to all
the others. It was Mary Magdalene,
Joanna, Mary the mother of James, and
the others with them who told this to
the apostles. But they did not believe
the women because their words seemed to
them like
nonsense. Peter, however, got up and ran
to the tomb. Bending over, he saw the
strips of linen lying by themselves, and
he went away wondering to himself what
had happened. And now read now is where
her question is relevant because she's
asking about the two on the road to
Emmas. Now read 13 all the way to 24.
Okay. Now that same day two of them were
going to a village called Emmas about
seven miles from Jerusalem. They were
talking with each other about everything
that had happened. As they talked and
discussed these things with each other,
Jesus himself came up and walked along
with them, but they were kept from
recognizing him. So you see that Marie
right there? The text is
self-explanatory. All we need to do is
read the text carefully to see that they
were kept. Now, why were they kept? This
would be a
consequence of their disbelief in the
words of Jesus Christ. In other words,
their refusal to believe what Jesus had
already told them was to take place
results in their inability to perceive
that the one standing before them is
Jesus. So that somehow when the Lord
appeared, he may have appeared veiled
with a robe with a hood. We're not told
exactly, but in some way, they're kept
from recognizing him. Number one,
because this would be the consequence of
their unbelief. Due to their unbelief,
they failed to perceive the one standing
before them as Christ. And number two,
they are kept temporarily from
recognizing him in order for the Lord
Jesus to use this as an abject lesson to
teach
them that they should have expected and
should have been
prepared for the death and resurrection
of Jesus because not only did he tell
them, but he told them that this is what
the prophets had announced beforehand
that Messiah would suffer and rise from
the
And yet, in spite of all that they were
told in advance, they still refused to
believe and therefore this was a
consequence of their sin. But then in
the in his mercy, the Lord comes to then
restore them and illuminate them so they
can
finally comprehend what should have been
comprehensible beforehand. But due to
their
unbelief and doubt, they were prevented
from recognizing him. So continue
reading now. Okay.
Okay. They were kept from recognizing
him. He asked them, "What what are you
discussing together as you walk along?"
They stood still, their faces
downcast. One of them named
Cleopus asked him, "Are you the only one
visiting Jerusalem who does not know the
things that have happened there in these
days?" "What things?" he asked. "About
Jesus of Nazareth," they replied. He was
a p a prophet powerful in word and deed
before God and all the
people. The chief priests and our rulers
handed him over to be sentenced to death
and they crucified him. But we had hoped
that he was the one who was going to
redeem Israel. And what is more, it is
the third day since all this took place.
In addition, some of our women amazed
us. They went to the tomb early this
morning, but they did not find his body.
They came and told us they had seen a
vision of angels who said he was alive.
Then some of our companions went to the
tomb and found it just as the women had
said, but they did not see Jesus. Did
you catch it again? Now, I hope Maria's
paying attention. This is an answer to
her question. Are you seeing what's
happening? You see how they're bearing
witness, testifying against
themselves. Notice they said it's the
third day. In other words, this is the
third
day. And they should have
expected Jesus to be raised from the
dead because he had told them in advance
that he, the son of man, would be handed
over to the Gentiles who'd be killed and
he'd be raised on a third day in
fulfillment of the prophecy. So notice
number one, they testify it's the third
day, which means they should have
expected Jesus to be raised and to
reappear. Number two, they then say that
a group of
women discovered the tomb empty. They
found the tomb empty and were informed
by angels that Christ had been raised.
That's why the body was not in the tomb.
And they still did not believe. And then
thirdly, thirdly it says some of the
male companions and earlier we're told
one of them was Peter went to verify
whether the tomb was empty and they
found it empty. So now notice they're
testifying against themselves. They are
clearly bearing witness that it's the
third day and Jesus already told them
that after he was killed he'd be raised
on a third day fulfilling the
prophecies. They still didn't believe.
The women discovered the tomb empty and
found angels who then announced to them,
"Christ is not here because he's been
raised." They still didn't believe. And
then the male witnesses went to verify
the tomb's empty and they still didn't
believe. So you see why they were
prevented from perceiving who who the
man was because of their unbelief. So
here you're being told by inspired
scripture that one of the consequences
of refusing to believe in God's
revelation is that even that little
illumination that you have can be taken
away from you if you refuse to submit to
the revelation that God has given you.
So even the little illumination that you
have to understand God's word, even that
can be taken away as
consequence, as punishment for your
refusal to believe due to your sin of
unbelief. I don't know if it's clear to
Marie, but let's now continue. Now you
stop at 24, read
25 all the
way to 32. Okay? He said to them, "How
foolish you are, and how slow to believe
all that the prophets have spoken." You
see, he's rebuking them, right? He's
reprimanding them. Did not the Messiah
have to suffer all these things and then
enter his glory? And beginning with
Moses and all the prophets, he explained
to them what was said in all the
scriptures concerning himself. As they
approached the village to which they
were going, Jesus continued on as if he
were going farther. But they urged him
strongly, "Stay with us, for it is
nearly evening. The day is almost over."
Let me explain what that means before
you go on, brother. And by the way, um
just uh let me explain. Notice it says,
"What did Jesus do?" Continuing as if he
was going further.
Now, less you misunderstand what Luke is
saying. Less you misunderstand what Luke
is saying. Jesus is not Allah. He
doesn't use. He doesn't use deception,
deceit. Jesus wasn't pretending to be
going his way. This was an
invitation. If they had not persuaded
Jesus to remain, he would have left. In
other words, Jesus now had given them a
choice. Either he could proceed and
leave
or they could invite him to come in and
stay and in that act of then persuading
him not to leave but to remain in that
act they'd be rewarded because now
they'd be illuminated to realize that
the person in front of them was none
other than Jesus in the flesh. So it's
their sinfulness that prevented them
from perceiving who Jesus was. And so
Jesus is leaving. Now the choice is
theirs.
Either you will allow him to leave or
you will insist that he stay. And by
inviting him
in the reward of that is now the veil
will be removed. So you can see clearly
that the one before you is Jesus Christ.
Is that clear to everyone? I just want
to make sure that I'm not confusing
anyone. And who's saying? Are you
getting it too, brother? Yeah, I'm
getting it too. I just got a just a tiny
little other thing from it, too. I just
want to just share, but it I I don't
want to change the subject. I'm not
changing it up because we'll we'll
finish it in a minute. And that is that
sometimes Jesus will be walking by us.
Yes. And he could just keep walking if
we don't invite him to come. Because
there's also a place where one time when
he was walking on the water and they
were in the boat and it it was as if he
would walk right by, but they called out
to him and he came after they called.
But there's times where Jesus will walk
by you. He's walking by and he's waiting
for an invitation. If you don't invite
him, he'll just walk by. Dude, 100%. You
got it. So, it's relevant to the point
I'm making. So, what you just said
perfectly dovtales with the point I
made. Exactly. Either Jesus will walk by
you or you'll invite him to stay and he
will accept your invitation and remain
with you and then bless you by granting
you the illumination to realize who he
truly is.
It's like the passage in Revelation
3:20, "Behold, I stand at the door and
knock. He who opens
up and lets me enter in, he will eat
with me and I will eat with him." That's
Revelation 3:20, right? Yes. So now
notice what the Lord then does when they
persist and insist that he stay and not
leave and provide him lodging in their
homes. Keep reading. Okay. When he was
at the table with them, he took bread,
gave thanks, broke it, and began to give
it to them. So he ate with them, right?
He sucked with them.
Keep going. Then their eyes were opened
and they recognized him and he
disappeared from their
sight. They asked each other, "Were not
our hearts burning within us while he
talked with us on the road and opened
the scriptures to us?" You see, so they
recognize that this was Jesus all along
once he broke the bread. Now this is
highly symbolic and again we trust the
Holy Spirit to fill us. May the Holy
Spirit fill Hussein and myself to
perfectly perceive understand the depth
of scripture, the meat of scripture and
bring it out clearly without error,
without stammering so we can feast on
the meat of scripture. Feast off the
flesh and the blood of Jesus Christ our
Lord for our salvation, healing,
nourishment, redemption in Jesus name.
May the father, son, holy spirit be
glorified. Now notice they invited him
in. He accepted their invitation. He
went to their home and he sucked with
them. Go to Revelation 3:20 because this
this is the perfect parallel to what you
just read. Here I am. I stand at the
door and knock. If anyone hears my voice
and opens the door, I will come in and
eat with that person and they with me.
Did you catch how this perfectly
parallels what we just read? Yes.
Because he's walking with them. He's
going to walk past
them and he'd continue walking past them
unless and until they invited him in and
then do that to invitation. The Lord now
blesses them by forgiving them of their
foolishness and hard-heartedness for not
believing what he had already told them
that the prophet said would happen to
him even though it was the third day.
Because remember they testified it's now
the third day. That
means that in itself should have been a
reminder. Wait, when Jesus was with us,
he told us that the prophets prophesied
that he, the son of man, the Messiah
would be killed and be raised on third
day. Therefore, if it's the third day,
we know who he is. He is the holy one of
God, the Messiah, the son of God, who
cannot lie. Therefore, we should expect
that he would appear because he'd be
raised just like he said and as the
prophets had prophesied. But instead
they doubted and disbelieved. And a
consequence of their disbelief is if
you refuse to believe the revelation
that God has given you and that
illumination that you've received to
understand the things that God has given
you, then one consequence of your
disbelief is that the Lord will even
take away that little illumination and
give you what you deserve. But
thankfully the Lord in his mercy didn't
give them what they deserve. He still
continued to show them grace. And it's
not coincidence that when did they fully
realize this one is none other than
Jesus raised from the dead? When he
broke the bread. because he had already
broken the bread
earlier that evening on the night of his
betrayal when he broke the bread and
says this is my body which is broken for
you. So in the breaking of the bed the
bread which simulates what Jesus did on
the night of his betrayal i.e the
Eucharist. Then their minds were open
and they realize that they're in the
presence of Jesus. So this is an
invitation. What's the invitation?
Partake of the Eucharist because at the
Eucharist, Jesus is giving himself to
you and you're being invited to feast
with Jesus. So the connection with
eating with Jesus, Revelation 3:20, when
do we eat with the Lord and he eats with
us at the Eucharist?
Jesus invites us to come and feast off
of him at the Eucharist, the breaking of
the bread and giving of the cup. You
making that connection, brother? Yeah.
And you know, another interesting thing
also is
that is that the Jesus was must have
been talking about this thing that he's
going to die, be raised, and I mean he's
going to be handed over to the Jews and
that they're going to crucify him.
They're going to bury him and they're
he's going to be raised in the third. It
must have not been a secretive thing
that he only told us because the Jews
knew about it. In Matthew, they said
that the deceiver said that he's going
to rise after three days. So the Jews
knew about it. So I mean it wasn't like
some secretive thing, you know. So, in
fact, go to Luke
18:31-34. So, I can show you just one of
the many times that Jesus himself had
announced to them beforehand. The
prophets prophesied that I, the Messiah,
son of man, will be handed to the
Gentiles to be beaten and killed, and
I'll be raised on the third day. So they
were told now Luke 18:31-34 notice
Jesus took the 12 aside and told
them we are going up to Jerusalem and
everything that is written by the
prophets about the son of man will be
fulfilled. He will be delivered over to
the Gentiles. They will mock him, insult
him, and spit on him. They will flog him
and kill him. on the third day he will
rise again.
And his disciples did not understand any
of
this. Its meaning. So notice they didn't
understand any of this. Why?
Its meaning was hidden from them and
they did not know what he was talking
about. Now why was it hidden from them?
Did God hide it from them or because of
their disbelief and
unbelief acting as a barrier from them
comprehending what was plainly told
them? I mean could Jesus have said it
any planer? I mean he just said I the
son of man will be handed over to be
killed in fulfillment of the prophecy. I
mean do you get any planer than that?
No. But so what prevented them from
comprehending and understanding what
Jesus said is their unbelief. Why? This
is a warning for all of us as the Holy
Spirit illuminates us to understand the
word. If you come to the text of
scripture with assumptions and
presuppositions already assuming what
God can and cannot be, God can and
cannot do. Those assumptions become a
sinful barrier from you accepting the
plain reading of the Bible.
The apostles of our Lord already had
certain assumptions about what the
Messiah can and cannot be like and what
the Messiah can and cannot do. Because
of those prior assumptions, those
assumptions prevented them from
accepting the plain clear teaching of
scripture that Messiah would be killed
and be raised on the third day. So it
was kept from them not by God but
because of their own unbelief and
disbelief. A disbelief that was the
result of their coming to God's word
with assumptions on what God's word can
and cannot say.